let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and
we've put together the best of the week
from the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the
week this is typical manga [ __ ] just
like the the video i have up here on the
screen typical [ __ ] they think like
this is this is um if you look here
close this is don jr here
uh booger sugar junior you know the
cokehead that is
uh donald trump's the former president's
son
and who who who is the laptop we should
actually be work looking for the cell
phone and the burners we should actually
be looking for the projection is strong
with this one and then we have eric
greitens
the the sex assaulter you know the the
former disgraced missouri governor who
duct taped his hairdresser to his
treadmill in his basement made her get
naked and took pictures of her while she
was blindfolded
and then
made her do sex acts
so that way he could use the pictures as
blackmail yeah that guy that [ __ ] guy
right there
eric greitens and don't don't believe me
when i say this [ __ ] about eric greitens
believe the republicans in missouri the
republicans in missouri are the ones who
did the investigation against eric
greitens and published the findings
which found that he duct taped his
hairdresser naked blindfolded to a
treadmill in his basement i'm not
[ __ ] you that [ __ ] is real you know
what else is real eric greitens is
running for united states senate in the
state of missouri
and kimberly guilfoyle is part of his
campaign or some [ __ ]
that's why booger sugar jr here decided
to go up and have a tough guy moment on
camera cause that's all this is
you ever met the guy in a bar who talks
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] who's gonna beat
everyone's ass oh he's gonna kick your
ass and he's gonna kick your ass and
he's gonna do this he's gonna do that
all that [ __ ] and then you get out
on the sidewalk and that that
[ __ ] gets his face pounded in
because he's all [ __ ] talk
all talk
yeah that's what these two are all
[ __ ] talk
everyone's saying this is dangerous and
of course it's [ __ ] dangerous because
they're sending a dog whistle
to people who are actually [ __ ]
dangerous
who would actually do the [ __ ] that
they're saying in the video
that's what they're doing here folks
they wouldn't actually do it they're a
bunch of [ __ ] they get their asses
kicked on the sidewalk in front of a bar
eric greitens and donald trump jr both
let's just watch this video let me make
it bigger for you so you can see
all the nonsense in this video
listen really closely to what don jr
says and then listen to what eric
greitens says we'll watch it a couple
times so you can catch it
oh so tough so tough they can shoot a
target whew baby bang bang bang bang
bang pew pew pew pew pew no liberal can
pick up a gun and shoot a target that's
not a thing liberals just can't handle
guns and shoot get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] liberals own guns dummies
liberals own a lot of [ __ ] guns
and frankly liberals are smarter with
their [ __ ] weapons i would say and
probably have less accidents fatal
accidents for that matter but let's
listen to what don jr says here strikes
your fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere striking fear in the hearts
of liberals everywhere i you i don't
fear you you dumb [ __ ] and
honestly if i was ever approached by
with with donald trump jr and he had a
[ __ ] rifle in his hand it would just
piss me off more than anything it would
piss me off more for him to approach me
if he had a firearm than if he didn't
have one it would just piss me off more
and i feel that way about anyone with a
firearm if you gotta walk around with a
[ __ ] firearm so you can order a
subway sandwich you are a [ __ ] you are
a [ __ ] weak piece of [ __ ] you are a
[ __ ] snowflake if you gotta carry
around a gun feel tough
that's what you are
just like donald trump booger sugar
junior here
and eric greitens in tow listen to what
this [ __ ] says
liberals beware
did you catch it
did you catch it he said liberals beware
liberals beware let's listen in the
hearts of liberals everywhere in the
heart and the striking fear and the
hearts of liberals everywhere and then
listen
liberals beware liberals beware what a
bunch of [ __ ]
what a bunch of goddamn snowflake
[ __ ]
but they have to
oh and a bunch of [ __ ] boxes they think
they're so [ __ ] tough
they think liberals are scared
of boneheads with guns you are a dumb
stupid son of a [ __ ]
if you think liberals are scared with a
of a bunch of boneheads with guns really
[ __ ] stupid breaking news
rand paul is a [ __ ] [ __ ] box that's
breaking news
right um apparently
apparently um rand paul has um let's see
let me read it here let me pull this uh
tweet up here um recount has it the clip
even um senator rand paul
the quote is now uh secretary anthony
blinken secretary of state anthony
blinken is testifying in the senate
today uh about the
the aggressor that is russia in um oh my
god
rand paul says the countries that have
been attacked georgia and ukraine were
part of the soviet union since the 1920s
secretary blinken says that does not
give russia the right to attack them so
let's watch the clip here of
of um
the bonehead rand paul
probably getting dunked in the [ __ ]
trash
by secretary blink which is not hard to
dunk um rand paul in the trash just ask
his neighbor let's listen
uh it has not attacked nato countries uh
for probably a very good you could also
argue the countries they've attacked
it here we go
uh it has not attacked nato countries uh
for probably a very good you could also
argue the countries they have attacked
were part of russia
well that
we're part of the soviet union yes and i
firmly disagree with uh with that
proposition it is the
fundamental right of these countries to
decide their own future in their own
destiny and not saying there's not but
i'm saying that the countries that have
been attacked georgia that is exactly
what you're saying you [ __ ] box and this
guy is propagating putin's message
from the seat of a committee hearing
this united states senator
in our senate chamber is propagating
putin's [ __ ] [ __ ] message about
how ukraine used to be part of the ussr
it's not anymore it wasn't the soviet
union is gone and ukraine has been a
democracy yeah not a perfect one but it
is a democracy and it is a sovereign
nation
so get the [ __ ] over it pluck your head
out of your ass and realize that rand
paul is fighting against democracy when
he's saying this [ __ ] yeah he is
propagating this is a dumb hill to die
on yeah
like to to go in and defend and be like
well
uh
justified they are russia right like i
don't know why i said like yoda there
but
uh
russia
like rand paul's coming in he's like
yeah russia uh they're totally justified
to uh attack ukraine and anyone else uh
yeah because a hundred years ago yeah
because a hundred years ago
they really they're like they they were
part of the ussr well regardless of you
know uh vladimir putin's desire to build
the ussr again or or the soviet union um
it doesn't justify
attacks now it's like going back and be
like well retroactively like they're
actually part of it they owned it like
they get to do whatever they want with
it because it's theirs here's a good
example
here's a good example to give rand paul
and all you [ __ ] trump bumpers out
there and you moglodites
here's the example california arizona
and new mexico it would be in texas it
would be like mexico saying we're just
gonna take that back that's ours it was
ours at one point that's ours how would
you feel and how would the united states
respond to mexico marching across the
border and committing war crimes to take
back texas arizona new mexico california
the the part that was mexico at one time
how would you [ __ ]
build a wall morons like that
again this is really [ __ ] dumb it's a
really bad take and the reason why it's
a bad take is because it's putin's lies
that are making their way into our
public record and again
i know it doesn't seem related but this
is why you have to focus when you're
[ __ ] electing your officials with
[ __ ] like 230 because rand paul cannot
be trusted to put his hands anywhere on
230. you cannot trust that [ __ ]
traitor if that [ __ ] traitor is
willing to propagate putin's message
inside our united states house our
senate chamber
then he is willing to put putin's
fingerprints all over any other
legislation that he 100
and the fact that this is you know again
like you said on the record right it's
the same [ __ ] that you know when uh matt
gates was like i've got the contents of
hunter biden's laptop on this thumb
drive one
uh why do you have the contents of the
laptop on a thumb drive that you're just
joking around with
two it has now been verified that things
were put onto a laptop after the fact
and three like
you don't have the actual original you
have something that was a copy of
something else so to say that that is
the actual contents or to say that it's
all bad in this in this thumb drive
you know would totally dismiss the fact
of like someone else doing something so
when i look at this i see this as
another thing where you know the gqp
throws in their
uh their voice to
you know um
do disinformation or spread
uh spread disinformation within the
committee so it goes on the record to be
like well they they
you know he made a point for this it
wasn't a great point but he made a point
for this maybe we should reconsider this
right right well margie makes a good
point here reign approves uh england
taking back the u.s i mean yeah you know
we can
we can play what about ism and go all
the way back right you know but
give it back to the dinosaurs tony the
fact of the matter is it's what linda
from facebook says rand paul is a
russian asset absolutely 100 percent
um even kalin points it out here john
mccain said it on the senate floor
pointed at rand ball john mccain when he
was still alive he pointed at rand paul
and said you're putin's puppet in other
words wu-tang for children has the
actual clip that we were talking about
earlier i want to watch this watch what
john mccain says about rand paul
legislative session
mr president
is senator from kentucky i object
objection is heard
this guy does nothing but object mr
president i know this associates
conversation well i mean i mean he
no just like anything else
he also objects to his neighbor kicking
his ass right and he's i'm just saying
you know but you look at you look at
anything when you're like oh what are we
doing like what was the uh what was the
c-span uh the vote that was happening
for uh wasn't it
uh contingent jackson brown yes well i
mean yeah he was the only one left they
were waiting on him i don't know if he
was wiping his ass after he took a [ __ ]
or what but they were they were waiting
for hey i don't know a good 10 or 15
minutes for this guy in to come in and
give us is no vote of course he was
going to vote no
but i mean i mean you know everyone is
always waiting
always waiting on on rand paul everyone
right well let's let's listen to what
john mccain says here
about his uh rand paul's objection
leaving the floor without justification
or route or any rationale for
the action that he has just taken
that is really remarkable
that a senator
blocking a treaty
that is supported by the overwhelming
number perhaps 98
at least of his colleagues would come to
the floor and object and walk away
and walk away
the only conclusion you can draw
when he walks away is he has no argument
to be made he has no justification
for his objection
to
having
a small nation
be part of nato that is under assault
from the russians so i repeat again
the senator from kentucky is now working
for vladimir putin i yield the floor
whoosh john mccain did not mince words
when it came to rand paul there yeah um
thank you uh wu-tang
for um bringing that to everyone's
attention and posting who is that from
um let's see if he's
uh never forget the time john mccain
said rand paul works for putin i believe
this was um i i think it was in two
did do
it was during the
um obama administration i believe 2017
yeah 2017. so it was no it was it was uh
after trump march 15 2017. okay so it's
a recent history not ancient history um
let's see if we can find some more clips
of this [ __ ] bonehead um
i don't want to play too many long clips
here of this this worm you know what
if rand paul is a worm maybe we should
give him ivermectin i'm just saying i
mean go for it i mean it looks like the
things in his hair are worms right maybe
maybe he's got worms in his [ __ ] head
boneheads
he doesn't own it yet and he didn't
march down to the twitter headquarters
with duffel bags full of 44 billion
dollars and they signed it over to him
that is not how it works
holy actual [ __ ] how and how in the hell
how in the hell is it that the right
wing is just [ __ ] stupid they they
think elon musk now owns twitter because
they accepted his bid yesterday that was
the news the news was that twitter
accepted
elon musk bid
for
twitter
in other words elon musk put a bid in on
twitter
they took it seriously because elon must
show how he would pay the 44 billion
they took that seriously and they
accepted the bid
elon musk does not own twitter today
frankly
i'm of the belief and you can prove me
wrong you can go back and roll the tape
and say oh you were [ __ ] wrong
i actually don't i i still
i still am very skeptical that elon musk
won't flake on this deal
you know how many deals elon musk flakes
on this guy won't even [ __ ] sit for a
full haircut i'm gonna prove it
he flakes on his barber for haircuts
what makes you think he might not flake
on this deal
and besides they've just accepted his
bid what if there's another bid that
comes in
really [ __ ] stupid that
self-proclaimed free market capitalists
in this country have no idea the
difference between a public a private
corporation they have no idea that elon
musk isn't going to just own twitter
he's going to own the corporation that
owns twitter
they have no [ __ ] clue that he is
actually
subject to federal state laws civil laws
criminal laws like this is so [ __ ]
stupid
it's really [ __ ] stupid did you know
did you know it one time in in our
nation's history that twitter the
company twitter was private
the company twitter was private until it
released its ipo its initial public
offering back in 2013.
it was started in i think 2006 is when
twitter became a thing
and it wasn't until 2013 until they
released their ipo
and became public to to get financing is
the reason why they went public
is to increase the size of their
company instead of going to a bank
they went the route of an ipo and
released
public stock to buy parts of their
company
oh man
three weeks were doing this elon musk
twitter blue balls [ __ ]
really is [ __ ] dumb
because elon musk and and again it's the
media the media out there oh [ __ ] he
bought it he didn't buy twitter yet
folks they accepted his bid
for the 44 billion
they accepted his offer
for the 44 billion he still has not
bought it yet there's a lot of [ __ ]
regulation and red tape to walk through
to take a company from being a pr a
public company like twitter is to being
a private 44 billion dollar
private corporation
and they have to follow all the laws all
the rules all the regulations they have
to do all that [ __ ]
again he's not gonna walk into the
twitter headquarters with duffel bags
full of 44 billion dollars and they just
hand him the keys and they all walk out
give me a [ __ ] break paige we are on
the books of face so if elon musk
destroys twitter we'll go i i don't know
everyone's like oh i'm gonna leave
twitter and i guess uh um i don't i know
his name i think it's talcum x he's a
rapper is that right i i've never heard
of
i think his name is sean king i've never
actually heard of heard of him before uh
i don't know i i'm not steeped in pop
culture but i i i don't know him but
apparently he already turned his account
off and of course the right wing's
cheering because he left what i mean i
don't understand
what that means
i mean you left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter and they're happy
that he left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter yet it really is
[ __ ] dumb
does it does everybody know that elon
musk doesn't own twitter yet
he doesn't own it yet
it's not his yet he doesn't he's not
running [ __ ] over there yet
it's still the same twitter police that
was before
it's not the elon police it's still it's
still the same [ __ ] that it was
yesterday
all they did is say hey that 44 billion
dollars that looks like a nice stack of
cash that's that's basically what
twitter did yesterday
is that looks like a nice static and
i've been getting a lot of [ __ ] you
don't know how this works you don't know
how that works elon's buying it tony
doubt me
doubt me i'm not saying i'm right or
wrong i'm i'm predicting that the deal
falls through that's actually what i'm
predicting i think the deal falls
through i don't think i think the media
is getting all hyped up everyone on
twitter is getting all hyped up and
that's exactly that's exactly what elon
musk wants that's what he wants
that's what he's here for is to punk
your dumb ass
come on
that's what i think
lisa says sean king is a social
uh activist tony yeah that that may be
true i i haven't heard of sean i might
have heard of sean before uh stumble
crossing but when i seen the name this
morning i didn't recognize it i didn't
recognize it i think it's i think it's
really
a dumb move
if he is an activist to not have a
microphone um you guys know
uh back when the joe rogan n word
controversy happened a lot of people
especially podcasters were were
boycotting spotify they were taking
their content down on spotify i will not
i will not
cower away from right wingers or nut
bags like elon musk i will not cower
away from them if if really what he
wants is freedom of speech which is all
[ __ ]
it's all he wants his freedom of speech
not everyone else's is what elon musk
means
let's face it
but i'm not gonna cower away from you
i'm not gonna cower away from spotify
i'm not gonna cower away from twitter
i'm gonna stay here and i'm gonna fight
that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be yelling and screaming until
the microphone they're gonna have to
drag me out of this hell hole to get me
off twitter for damn sure elon musk is
gonna have to grab me by the short and
curlies and open my uh open the door
with my head that's the expression
telling you calm down everybody he
doesn't own twitter yet and he's a flake
he's a flake let me prove it here let me
prove it
i'll give you proof
i'm gonna show you proof this is this is
proof that he's a flake
i know this seems trivial
but this is true here's a picture of
elon musk
with a haircut look at this here i'll
make it bigger
he flaked on his haircut this is not a
finished haircut he did not even let he
did not even let
the barber finish his haircut look at
this guy
does this look like a guy that finishes
anything
come on
give me a break
give me a break
oh
oh here brad brad's upset
brad ford is upset he said unsubbed
apparently i'm stupid eat [ __ ] if you
stay on twitter you're part of the
problem bye brad see you later dude
look if you're if you're upset about
speech
my speech especially if you're upset
about my speech especially well goodbye
see you later sayonara even brett says
idiots goodbye
really this is dumb this is dumb
if you're gonna leave twitter then leave
[ __ ] it leave
go where where are you gonna go you're
gonna go to facebook oh you think you
think facebook isn't run by a
knucklehead
you think the metaverse isn't run by a
[ __ ] knucklehead
oh tick-tock oh that's much better over
there go over to tick-tock what about
instagram uh you know facebook owns
instagram can't go there where are you
gonna go you're gonna go to parlor
you're gonna go to get her you're gonna
go to true social get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] come on get real get
real folks
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize
realize that elon musk has not bought
twitter yet
he's not
i'm predicting that he won't that's
right everyone's like oh he's he's
bought twitter he's bought it it's a
deal it's not a deal they just accepted
a bid this is going to take months and
months and months to put this deal
together and this guy here on the screen
well that guy right there that guy right
there
who couldn't sit for an entire haircut
and flaked on his barber here huh
flaked on his barber
this guy
this guy
isn't gonna flake on this deal come on
he's punking you he's punking and maybe
maybe um
jay says i'm still in denial
i'm still in denial which i mean that
may be that may be i i may have this
delusion
that that elon musk doesn't flake on
things but he does he's been proven to
he said a lot of things that he was
gonna do and really frankly i'm kind of
pissed off about the 44 billion dollars
i am i'm really [ __ ] pissed off about
it here's why do you know do you know
what 44 billion dollars would do
for children
in schools do you have any [ __ ] idea
what 44 billion dollars could do
to feed hungry people in this country do
you have any [ __ ] idea
that's what we should be pissed about
that we are not taxing this [ __ ]
into oblivion
that's right if elon musk can afford to
buy a public company for 44 billion
dollars we should tax the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of him
that's what we should be pissed off
about this morning if you're gonna be
pissed off about something don't be
pissed off about he owns twitter be
pissed off that we didn't tax him enough
that that [ __ ] can buy a private
company for 44 billion dollars
this guy can just [ __ ] out 44 billion
and he's bitching on tv on interviews
about us taxing him
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
so if you want to go
go
unsub leave i don't give two shits and
if you think i'm gonna give a [ __ ] and
not give my opinion on something your
your mistake you are in the wrong
[ __ ] place if you think i am
not to give my opinion on what i think
about politics or the social and
economical
position that our country's in
you have not been around long enough of
the tony michaels podcast you have not
that's for goddamn sure
speaking of weirdos and interviews
uh have you seen this video by the good
liars this one here it's so hard to keep
up i feel like this one this one's a gem
as you see here uh this guy here i told
you earlier this has got jfk enter
junior enters the chat if you look here
he's wearing a shirt that says trump
plus jfk junior 2021
so his shirt that he's wearing to this
rally is already outdated um these
people i don't get it 2021 like do they
think that there was a special election
that was going to happen i don't know
where jfk junior all of a sudden went
and became a conservative these are all
good questions these are all really
really good hard-hitting questions these
are the questions i try to avoid but
somehow you make me ask them tony right
exactly well this is how it works and it
looks like a husband and wife beer here
i'm not really sure their relation
please don't procreate well yeah but
they're asking
they're asking
you mean jfk junior and this guy or
these the husband oh just these two like
you know i'm just well i'm just you know
couple brain cells rubbing together here
right but this appears to be um
outside the gated parking area as we
know the gate in the parking areas now i
can lock you in you can't leave leave
the rallies we've heard that from the
fence and that's got barbed wire over
there yeah it looks like a prison almost
like a trump prison but listen listen to
the dialogue and listen
well listen to the theories because
you've seen the video where the person
thought that princess diana was still
alive right you've seen that one yep
yeah yeah yeah okay now listen to what
this that was on and that was on the uh
that was on a news station right for
uh right or rsbn or whatever right they
were airing it as if it was news yeah
they're like hey this is good listen to
what this lady says about
joe biden and jim carrey i think she's
watching too many movies and getting
movies confusion
listen here listen you think biden is
not alive right now the guy that's doing
the stand up job of trying to wake
people up is an actor wearing a mask i
mean he's an actor wearing a mask okay
so he's got a mask on jim carrey did
play biden on snl
right and he did do a movie called the
mask the mask but listen in listen in
several different people playing joe
biden at this point and when when he
fell up the stairs going on the airplane
so you remember the video yeah yeah yeah
i remember wind was blowing he kind of
stumbles a bit he struggles to get you
know
joe biden isn't is an old guy but he
doesn't struggle to go down a ramp or
really up a ramp he doesn't go sometimes
you trip on the stairs right i mean this
is a presidential moment that happens a
lot i mean you can drink with water with
one hand
right right he can use right only one
hand i have a good story after the show
for you gabe that we might we might do
something with this about uh and well
we'll have to do that but i don't want
to give it away on air but anyways
the moment a lot of people don't
understand like an airport there's a lot
of wind right and and they always have
open steps to get into air force one
they're not hooked to the terminal or
anything right and and there's a lot of
wind so a lot of times when you're
coming down or going upstairs there's a
lot of wind so if you stumble but here's
the thing
is listen to who she thinks actually
stumbled it was joe biden i'll admit
that but listen who she thinks it was
they swapped i myself think that that
was jim carrey i've heard that he was
one of them
good night goodbye i'm done this this
lady this lady thinks that jim carrey is
the one
who who fell down the steps
um or fell up the step well whatever
again she's getting she's getting a
couple things confused here listen to
the question he asked hey
wait wait wait you think that jim carrey
was wearing a mask
and
was the acting president and being silly
by falling up the stairs three different
times she literally she's watching
footage of the president united states
she's watching snl as you alluded to
that jim carrey plays joe biden on snl
and then she's watching the movie the
mask i think
and she's really kind of getting these
things they watch way too many [ __ ]
movies man these crazy wackadoo q and on
folks watch way
too much tv they watch way too many
movies it is absolutely insane it gets
it gets better gabe it gets better
it gets so much better here
and james woods also i think is one of
them
james woods is a is a biden actor oh
that's what she's saying that's what
she's saying that's what she's saying
here at the end listen uh let me pull it
back let me pull it back here listen
and james woods also i think is one of
the
doppelganger mask wearing
people
so here's the thing here's the thing
james woods and jim carrey are
doppelgangers with mask on which is not
doppelgangers are not
they don't i i don't know if you know
what doppelganger means but
james woods is a conservative he is
right trump
humping conservative but gabe who better
to play joe biden than someone who would
implement the policies that you'd want
to implement so when gas when gas prices
go up wait no no no no no no that was
that no that was yeah that was
that was jim carrey doing that that was
jim carrey
this is
this is what we have to contend with and
and really honestly i i said this before
you came in the air
these people are getting dumber and
dumber and dumber at his rallies and
it's not surprising that the the dumb is
staying with him and the people who
aren't completely [ __ ] delusional and
lost their minds and just off their
rockers are starting to peel away from
him that's why i believe we're seeing
dumber and dumber at his rallies
not to be confused with the jim carrey
movie dumb and dumber but it is it is
starting to leak into fantasy really
i
yeah i just i knew it would leave you
speechless i don't even know what like i
you you you listen to that and you go
what
right like if there's no there's no
other way to be like oh like is she is
she punking like the big the the good
liars like is that what she's doing you
know and it's like no this is actually
someone who legitimately 100
lives in a reality where she believes
biden isn't really biden or has actors
who are playing biden which is a
comedian known as jim carrey and a
right-wing nut job former actor uh uh
straight to dvd james woods who you know
it's like it doesn't make any sense it
it well is it supposed to that's the
thing here again i've said this over and
over again we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life and on one s
on one corner there's the facebook iver
mekton group and then on the other
corner is the q and on headquarters i
just feel like soon it's just becoming
100 percent wrestlemania like that's
what like there is no really yeah real
life reality is leaving the right
one-way street and there is no
intersection it's just uh it's just uh
it's straight
somebody at one point was like hey maybe
this is a two-way and they're like no
one way dirt road kiwinot avenue
absolutely terrified of bananas
what in the [ __ ] is going on what is
going on
bananas
pineapples tomatoes
killer killer fruit and vegetables
oh man for a guy who's never seen a
fruit or vegetable on his plate it
really is it
really is alarming that he thinks fruits
and vegetables are dangerous
they're dangerous
flying around oh my god
this is real
it's it's [ __ ] real and he didn't
just like say this like in some dumb ass
interview
some
[ __ ] [ __ ] from some trader tv news
network type thing
no
he said this under oath
in a deposition
literally he swore an oath to tell the
truth nothing but the truth so help him
trump
this [ __ ]
is terrified of hecklers
throwing dangerous fruit at him
can you imagine
can you imagine
if if they
were to toss a banana at my face
and then i'd have to wipe it off and all
my makeup
and all the [ __ ] i take off my face
comes off with that banana
oh my god he's scared of nanners folks
he's scared of the nanners
oh [ __ ] i'm i'm not kidding you if
you're just hearing this donald trump
said in a [ __ ] deposition under oath
this is not again this is not some dumb
[ __ ] interview
this is not just [ __ ] steve bannon or
fox news or
whatever the [ __ ] traitor tv network
that you're that you're out there
[ __ ] having the cheeto dust mobster
on where he's talking about how people
are throwing
[ __ ] at him you know you remember the
kansas soup thing i made a joke about it
this morning when he was talking about
cans of soup and people antifa throwing
cans of soup and [ __ ]
you remember that
back when he was president
no it wasn't like that he was under oath
and he's talking about how
fruits and vegetables
are dangerous if they're thrown at him
and he's he's scary he's he's he's
really frightened that hecklers would
throw dangerous
dangerous nanners at him
oh my god can you imagine if a mater hit
me oh [ __ ] that would be
it'd be deadly
i don't know maybe he thinks maybe he
thinks fruits and vegetables are [ __ ]
deadly maybe that's why he only eats big
macs
and buckets of kfc
it could be i don't know i don't know
there's a lot of [ __ ] that this guy
seems to believe that is absolutely
[ __ ] bunkers bat [ __ ] crazy
whoosh
whoosh
under oath
he said
that
someone chucking
a banana at him is dangerous
now do you remember
the end of
george w bush's
tenure as president it was a second term
coming to the end i forget he was in a
foreign country we might pull up the
video here in a minute
and a guy takes off his shoe takes off
his shoe and tosses it at that
[ __ ] you remember that
it was actually kind of weird because
like
that just
doesn't happen with the secret service
standing there and it took a little bit
to
you know get the guy and for secret
service come in me remember that right
and the guy threw the shoe at george w
bush when he was the president of the
united states
and even the coward that george w bush
might be he at least ducked and he still
stood there he was like oh there's got
to be another shoe this motherfucker's
got two shoes i mean you know he
expected another shoe right
like he thought uh well there's one
where's the second one
right but donald trump is terrified
terrified of a bunch of bananas
whoo
as if we don't have better [ __ ]
[ __ ] worry about but that's hilarious
that is [ __ ] hilarious that this is
their macho machismo this this is the
guy they look to to be a tough manly man
tucker carlson tends his balls to look
like donald trump's face
so that he can be manly like donald
trump
you gotta have the trump face tan balls
to be a manly man
and here he is terrified of maters
good morning rachel how are you
what's happening
oh man there is a lot of there's a big
pile of [ __ ] to go through with these
peers this week i mean ever since ever
since marjory taylor green took the
stand um we know that now her name is
her i i call her marjory hoof foot green
but now we know it's marjorie perjury
green we have madison cawthorne who
oh can't stop rolling through a big pile
of dog [ __ ] excuse the expression um and
then i have a video that i want to play
for you that i seen this morning
and you you know senator kennedy down in
louisiana this this
just
he he he deems people on the left as
wokers have you heard this
yes oh my god i i want to show you this
because
it's so weird
it's so weird but let me let me play it
real quick because i i love i love i
actually love how he says this he's
trying to be funny yeah um but what he's
doing is he's walking right right into
the point but let's listen twit twitter
is run
by wokers wokers represent the crank
wing of the democratic party
uh wokers as i've said before easy to
recognize most of them eat food
only fit for rabbits now we we know we
know rachel that that that the
republicans are completely terrified of
fruit and vegetables this week because
the pres the former president united
states the cheetos mobster grandpa poopy
pants donald trump is deathly afraid he
even even swore under oath that he's
terrified of killer tomatoes no so it's
not surprising
this is crazy right why why why do we
have to
uh play this kind of stuff in this
political discourse have they really
fallen this far excuse the expression
from the apple tree i mean is that is it
is that what's going on what the hell is
going on here
yeah i mean you know this is a party
that
i think also in the news this week was
me trying to remind people like this is
not the same republican party that was
in office 10 years ago almost right all
of the crazy conservatives from 10 years
ago got replaced by people who were bat
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuts they got broken out in
ideological primaries something that
you've never seen on the left you see
one exception right aoc beating crawly
out and that um you know you catch an
incumbent with their pants down like uh
david brat caught eric cantor on the
other side it can happen right right um
so um but yeah but we watched
2010 2012
2014 um and 2016
wash out
really everybody who had been treated
like in the conservative caucus that
newt gingrich ran okay right right from
the back
back in the early 90s when they were
trying to run the great american plan i
forget what the hell it was but you know
that was their grand scheme right yeah
yeah and like here's here's a really
good way to encapsulate this okay and
like you can literally watch like their
moderates get purged by ideological
extremism
in these nominate these uh ideology
scores that we have for members of
congress that are particularly good
measurements right so you can watch that
happen but you also see
moderate dems like the blue dog caucus
in the south in 2014 get wiped out and
they get replaced moderate dems that are
like you know right in the center
replaced with ideologues like tom cotton
okay right right and then you see
somebody like rubio when he ran in 2010
he was a tea party i mean i think it was
2010 might have been 2014 but pretty
sure it was 2010. he came in as a tea
party
yo guy david jolly was supposed to run
in that that race or run against rubio
and uh yeah i'm mixing that up so anyway
yeah rubio comes in and he's the tea
party like he's part of the young guns
caucus right and now
like if you asked the crazy caucus the
coup caucus which is not a small group
of people if rubio's in the club they'd
be like oh hell no he's total
establishment dude okay so like this guy
that was once so ideological
that he was on in the tea party
rebellion is now considered what we
would call a sane republican today right
right right
well you know what let me finish up the
video here because what he says like
they try to be populist but like eating
vegetables eating salad is somehow not
cool anymore like it's woke to eat salad
i and honestly i eat you eat meat right
i i mean i do i was a vegetarian for
four years why did you forget those
thanksgiving turkeys back so don't do
that [ __ ] oh well you know i eat the
shittiest meat too like i'll eat hot
dogs
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll walk down some [ __ ] hot dogs
hell yeah salami [ __ ] pepperoni i
don't give a [ __ ] beef jerky you [ __ ]
ain't right i'm gonna eat that [ __ ] so
why they think people on the left only
eat vegetables i mean i i don't get it
but let's listen to also what they think
what what kennedy thinks they do they
almost always enter a swimming pool by
the stairs
they also don't believe in free speech
almost always enter the pool
that's right that's right i don't i have
no i actually like i don't know if he
like improv that or he thought that he's
like okay let's see what is more woke
than anything ever
it's probably walking down the stairs
into the pool as opposed to doing a
cannonball
i just thought that was an old person
thing you know i thought that was
generational right well right right i i
don't or someone who doesn't want their
swimming suit to come off because they
dive in the pool i i don't understand i
don't ever dive in but i will tell you
in my old age like i used to do the
polar air plunge [ __ ] no matter and and
i'm back in oregon there's no humidity
in the air here right so it can get very
cold even in the summer to swim and i
used to go full balls to the wall jump
in
total shock to the system and now i'm
old and i have to like i have to ease
into that [ __ ] dude
right
yeah
i think it has to do with being broke
right that's right that's right you know
what
i i don't mean to act like that kennedy
is somehow this clip of him and somehow
you know we should be reacting to it
politically but really it does show you
how the establishment because kennedy at
one time i mean and he still could be
called the establishment i'm i'm sure
the q and honors would be like oh he
kennedy
he's not he's he's jfk junior's cousin
or something
carlson is doing right he's framing
kevin mccarthy as a liberal right right
he's like we can't let kevin mccarthy
take over the speakership because we'll
have a republican-controlled congress
led by two liberals right right mccarthy
and mcconnell
and that's and that's what kennedy's
doing here essentially is he's trying to
placate to this that's why he's framing
the left as wokers and this swimming
pool vegetables thing i don't understand
it but here's here's the thing here's
the thing is that this is very
significant in in the kevin mccarthy
what you just brought up and even
kennedy doing this weird thing where
he's talking about swimming bulls and
walking in down the stairs and eating
vegetables they're terrified of killer
tomatoes but here's the thing is that
they really are they really are framing
up the 2020 midterm because they're
watching all these trump candidates
because these primaries are coming right
rachel and we're going to see if the
trump candidates are actually going to
win or not um
yeah oh they will they will and and
steve bannon was freaking out i think i
believe it was yesterday i posted a clip
of steve bannon freaking out on his
trader tv cable news channel whatever
the [ __ ] it is um he actually he's
freaking out because purdue is 27 points
behind in a poll in georgia and that's
the trump endorsed candidate um and and
so there's a little bit of a freak out
especially with georgia because they see
that as a strike there not just for the
governor because they can get rid of
kemp and say yeah trump won but they can
also steal that seat back away from uh
warnock um because he's in a special he
was in a special election in the runoff
as we know and now he has to run for the
actual seat yeah this is going to be a
brutal cycle in georgia but he does have
they have the best two campaigns uh the
abrams campaign right
campaign in georgia and then the beto
campaign in texas in terms of modernized
strategy and messaging okay
and had they not run that stuff in uh
2021 in the special in the general to
get there they would not have made it
where they made it and it did take a
perfect storm of some decreased turnout
in north georgia from republican voters
but ultimately at the end of the day i
mean they turned out like the turnout
raids that the abrams operation got in
that state was just really amazing but
even with all of that in their favor and
because republicans control the voting
process and restricted access it is
going to be a tremendous lift to hold on
to those seats
well and and i think that's a good point
because we can't we can't just look at
this poll in in georgia and see that the
trump candidate is behind kemp because
that's really what is happening is that
the trump candidate purdue who was the
senator who lost is running for governor
in the primary against the current
incumbent governor
kemp and if it wasn't open tony let me
tell you if it was an open race and so
like really to me the trump candidate
comparison to watch is not
um purdue getting his ass handed to him
right in georgia where he's trying to
take on the governor they brought to to
to to brought in so the kemp that
recorded the phone call a 90-minute
criminal conspiracy with donald trump
has been um you know he's been properly
brought back into line
he's never going to be purdue
right produce literally running on a lie
about election fraud it's as fascist as
you could possibly position yourself in
terms of 2020 messaging
but he's up against this this fact that
that the kemp machine there's i mean
there's just a very tight republican
party lock on that kemp machine is very
powerful
but where we really need to look is ohio
because what you're going to see is jd
vance and jd vance is the trump pick
he's being financed by him one of his
friends peter thiel who by the way is
has done much more to put us where we
are than the koch brothers and they have
done a [ __ ] ton okay so you should
really google up you know peter thiel
t-h-i-e-l if you have never read about
him oh i've heard about him
but with vance i mean vance is on audio
on this radio interview and he's he says
flat out we're going to dismantle the
left's institutions we're going to get
all purge out all the civil servants so
a civil servant for folks who don't
understand that a bureaucrat they're
they're they are hired on merit and
skill now they used to be it used to be
a patronage system where if you were
friendly with the party in power you got
the position you may not be good for it
but you got it right like trump trump
promoting right and uh but our civil
servants is not just not political it is
isolated intentionally firm politics
vance says on this radio show we're
going to wipe them all out and replace
them with quote our people
and then when the federal courts tell us
we can't do it we're going to thumb our
nose at the courts and say send in your
court army which is a quote to andrew
jackson right and it is also a threat to
completely pull the rug out from our
entire constitutional order to be clear
and that is going to be our senate front
runner in ohio and because of the nature
of ohio its de-alignment
it's um you know a very high likelihood
that he'll be elected
you know that that race is a is a very
interesting relation some of these
debates that have been happening because
i'm glad you brought up some of these
other races because if you look to the
pennsylvania race where dr [ __ ]
excuse me dr oz is running um it really
like they just i mean they can't say the
word trump enough like it is really
gross and sick
that they they just they just can't help
but they really do believe that he's
going to deliver them this victory um
even though 8 million more people voted
against him um in the last election but
they still believe that so tell me tell
me about some of these other debates
that you've seen
and how do you feel about the midterm at
this point i know we've talked about it
before and the generic ballot being so
important do you think that these
candidates that you've seen in these
debates now that we've kind of seen them
go back and forth in their primary
debates with the republicans do you
think that those candidates are going to
be able to talk to that generic ballot
or do you think democrats are going to
be able to coalesce a message to make
sure that the german the generic ballot
hears the democratic message over the
highly amplified trump message that's
right i mean as as of today tony i can
tell you that that is not what's going
to happen um you know the strategy
that's been put forward by the party is
to micromessage each of these races uh
try to put them into a localized chamber
this is not a new strategy it's the same
strategy just packaged differently and i
guess they feel like it's novel it's the
same one that lost us 2010 and 2014
huge wave elections
and so that generic ballot that i keep
talking about has not moved since it
crash you know it um flipped over to
favor republicans i think at the end of
2021 and has stayed there ever since and
in is in fact not changed even after we
moved out of that two-month three-month
nightmare legislative you know in party
fighting mansion cinema news cycle and
moved into ukraine and all of the things
that have come since
all of the good um you know things that
have happened in addition to you know
ongoing troubles obviously none of that
has moved it right because what it will
take to move the generic ballot is as
you just pointed out a concerted
concentrated intentional strategy that
is geared at winning the top-line public
debate
so let me ask you what what it what what
can what can people do out there to make
sure that that messaging is there um
obviously there might not be a heavy
lifting done by the institutions
in in in the democratic party the only
pro-democracy party that we have in this
country right now and they don't see the
risk maybe what what can be done
by just average people who definitely do
not want to see their democracy
destroyed i mean what can they do what
do they say to people in their community
what is the message what are two or
three sentences two or three questions
that they can ask someone they know to
start that conversation because we may
have to do this ourselves rachel
yeah i mean honestly and like if you've
got friends on the left i mean those are
probably the easiest and most important
people for you to hit because what
you're going to see when you talk to
them is oh i'm mad because i didn't you
know they didn't do anything
right
that's van jones that's van jones this
morning by the way i don't know i'm sure
yeah yeah and so like your job is to re
help them redirect their anger where it
belongs okay and that it does not belong
on the democratic party it belongs on
the republican party because as long as
the republican party has
a stranglehold on the senate pretty much
from the filibuster
we will not pass they will not pass any
[ __ ] thing it doesn't matter what you
want
it doesn't matter who's the president
you can put bernie sanders in there and
you're still not getting anything beyond
executive [ __ ] orders out of this
congress in fact you might have gotten
less right so at the end of the day when
people if people are pissed off about
where they stand today they need to be
told number one
this is why we didn't get [ __ ] done and
it wasn't joe manchin okay joe manchin's
responding what's he responding to to a
republican electorate so our problem is
we've got to get our ire
properly focused and van jones and
others like him do nothing to do that
all they do is whine and [ __ ] about our
own party and they just give republicans
a pass like oh well because these people
are obstructionist and not no longer
interested in governing then we're just
going to assume everyone understands
that premise and then starts the
discussion without including them and
it's just so damaging because the people
the audiences that are influenced by
that commentary don't have the same
education and context of government and
how it works as a van jones or rachel
bittikoffer does so when i hear that i
know what they mean but a lot of the
audience doesn't and so when they hear
the stuff what they what when you ask
them what's the problem they're like
well i guess it must be the democrats
the democrats are the problem it's a
matter of will right right well this is
always always with the will
right well this is always what the
republicans have been really good at is
making an enemy and we we have always we
have always made ourselves the enemy
just like van jones is doing this
morning or last night whenever the hell
the clip was i don't know when the hell
he said this he was basically saying
that joe biden and the democrats have
done nothing and it was all the like
like voting rights and everything else
shut the [ __ ] up the house passed voting
rights there is 50
50 republicans and not a damn one of
them in the house who voted for voting
rights it's not the democrats who didn't
vote for democrat for voting rights
that's all [ __ ] and van jones needs
to you know shut his trap but he's got
the he's got the right to speak but
here's what we also have the right to do
is to call him out on his [ __ ] and
to call everyone else on their [ __ ]
and amp
just like get them to understand like
what you are doing when you do this
is suppressing our own vote and the
really [ __ ] up part tony is the entire
reason the republican party created the
obstruction strategy which they did in
that restaurant back in 2009 on the eve
of the inaugural is for this so that
they could deny democratic office
holders any [ __ ] victory to take home
and run on so you are literally doing
the gop's bidding if you sit at
elections because you feel like
democrats aren't delivering
right right well because again i go back
to there is only one party in this
country that is interested in democracy
and we've seen this this week with the
tapes of kevin mccarthy being such a
[ __ ] coward i mean here is a guy
who's supposed to be their leader he's
supposed to be the one in charge and
he's he not only not only did he not
stand up for his convictions that he had
in those calls but then then when he
gets called out on on the phone calls
and the [ __ ] he said bad about donald
trump he says no that's a [ __ ] lie i
didn't say any of that [ __ ] the tapes
get released and he looks like a [ __ ]
coward and it's drip drip drip drip drip
and it's obvious it's obvious now why
some of these republicans the few liz
cheney and some others
said you know what i know these phone
calls were [ __ ] recorded i know
they're gonna have us on tape and kevin
mccarthy didn't give a [ __ ] because he
doesn't care about democracy he doesn't
really care about his constituents he
doesn't care about policy he only gives
a [ __ ] about one thing and one thing
only and that's remaining in power that
is
right that's right
kevin's power right right
yeah well be because we seen soon after
these calls were recorded and we've we
listened to these calls all week um
after he was you know saying he was
gonna which is all [ __ ] he was just
pandering to the people that were on the
phone call as far as i could tell i
really thought he was gonna go tell
trump to resign give me a break kevin
mccarthy he
soon after that he got on a plane went
to mar-a-lago put his cheeto dust knee
pads on and was kissing the ring and
changing diapers i mean this is [ __ ]
ridiculous that kevin mccarthy was gonna
be a tough guy it's it's absolutely
bonkers to me that that is their leader
and and we with all this with all this
election
that the stuff that we have to run on
they're setting the ball up on the t for
us all we have to do is get a national
message out there and continue to pound
that message and continue to make an
enemy
for democracy because they truly are
they're trying to commit a coup as we
speak in arizona we see we see people
like carrie lake running for governor
who want to who want to overturn the
last election and we're almost we're
closer to the next one than we are from
the last one and she wants to overturn
that one still i mean these people are
out of their minds they're not for
democracy they're not for a republic
they're not their their fascist is what
they are and their leader is some weak
coward kevin mccarthy who's willing to
stand aside for his own for his own
power and let them take over and do
whatever they want and run rough shot
over the people and democracy and
they're getting a bigger ceasefire media
who continues to treat
things like you know these purdue
comments in the debate they're so
disturbing they're absolutely
disqualified no americans should be able
to be on any ballot anywhere for any
elected office with those kinds of
public views and yet our media never
wants to talk about hey the republican
party is running people who should not
be
packed because they're advocating openly
for insurrection or
you know um the coup
conspiracy that was executed by their
party right i mean this it's so [ __ ]
weird to me
even though i've really spent a lot of
time now digging into these other
societies that have crumbled
it's just so weird to me that the media
is dead silent on the abnormality of
this republican party and that i'm the
one that has to come and remind people
this party went through an internal
civil war that started in 2010
escalated in 2014 when cantor got
bounced and they decided to disavow the
republican big ten autistic autopsy
report that the party had put together
after 2013 and when you see the divide
for the never trumpers who left the
party that was the autistic team they're
like hey we can't win national elections
if we're a bunch of racist [ __ ] so
let's try to moderate ourselves on on
immigration and a few other things and
not go native this because that's going
to give us that's going to make our
electorate white problem even worse and
they lost they they had a chance to win
that debate until cantor got tossed
and then they lost and with trump coming
down that golden escalator in may of
2015 and them not rejecting him him
rising through the ranks paul ryan
normalizing him after he secured the
nomination that they put the cap on the
old republican party and and sealed it
away
and this thing that we're fighting now
is a different beast and the media just
never wants to give that context it's
very dis doesn't disheartening
well you know they are in the trump loop
and the other thing that they do is this
bulls side [ __ ] like oh both sides both
sides are you know look what how bad the
democrats are doing and but but you know
republicans you know they're still you
know and they normalize it like you're
saying right like they and and the other
problem that we have is that people so
many people in this country pay
attention to right-wing media and i
think one of the reasons why is because
you know everyone says all the
mainstream media is left-wing and that's
all [ __ ] there isn't a left-wing
media apparatus like there is no big
huge
huge apparatus that is left-wing media
that can push a left-wing a true
left-wing message that says [ __ ] you to
fascism yeah when when when you have cnn
like
nodding their head as van jones is
basically
get serving up on a platter what the far
right wants which is van jones a black
guy who was in who was in the obama
administration basically parroting their
points on cnn they say hey look hey look
libtards hey look you [ __ ] libs here's
here's a guy on cnn he's an obama guy on
cnn giving you how bad or how bad bob uh
biden sucks and and
it just it just is infuriating that
everyone thinks that's what we need to
consider tony that he actually wasn't in
the obama administration because he
couldn't get confirmed
that's the far left the part the far
right wants fascism the far left the
radical socialists
want to talk about climate change want
to talk about not going broke over a
medical bill they want their kids to
start school at three instead of five
they they want to make sure they're not
[ __ ] broke their entire lives because
they go to college to make sure that
they're economically sound in their
career so these are the things that are
supposed to be radical and extreme not
marrying children in tennessee not not
basically taxing floridians to get rid
of a private industry which is their
biggest tourist industry which is disney
because disney somehow woke because they
support equity and equality for human
beings this is really
and
and you're telling me
making sure that college is affordable
and people start their education at
three instead of five and making sure
people don't go broke because of a of a
medical bill that's extreme this is
really what they are giving us
everything we need to message yeah well
i mean keep in mind how do you define
liber i mean i think i just tweeted
about this before the show i said you
know today a liberal is defined by
somebody who trusts science reads actual
news and watches actual news and
believes in diversity and equality all
right i mean if that makes me a [ __ ]
woman how dare you yes so right how
scary rachel got very clear that there's
one party
that lives in reality land
and reads
information
you know and there's another one that's
completely [ __ ] looney tunes right
and and that looney tunes is not
something that's a punch line or like a
abstract the way the clinton team tried
to focus on trump
that looney tunes is going to be in
charge of you
[Laughter]
right
well and that's and that goes back to
the clip i played in the beginning
is is kennedy because he's playing to
the [ __ ] looney tunes and he truly
believes that these people he believes
that these people listening fox news are
stupid enough to believe that people who
walk down the stairs into the pool are
somehow part of the disney woke crowd i
mean ron desantis was on stage talking
about how disney was
creating cartoon porn or some [ __ ] and
sexualizing cartoons i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you dude number one it it you
people do not have disney plus you're
not watching in kanto and and by the way
you're not watching all the cartoons
that walt disney made that sexualized uh
cartoons and women give me a break
looney tunes disney have always
sexualized women have always sexualized
cartoons you people you people are the
ones who are sexualizing kid's gender
how many of them took their kids to go
see who framed roger rabbit right
[Music]
their first group of children was back
in the 90s and now they've all divorced
their old hags and married their
mistresses you know their 17 year old
child brides have had me all right
i mean they aren't they are the new
republican kid diddlers i mean they
really are they before i jump off i got
a very important question for you yes
all right
let's say i walk into the pool using the
stairs but
i'm eating a slice of pepperoni pizza am
i still well [ __ ]
don't do not i i can't even i can't even
begin to describe you how if we pose
this question
to the fastest republicans how their
heads
you know what you should do you should
go go tweet that and tag kennedy
this is something that we got away
i know but these are important matters
rachel thank you for joining us now
everyone stick around right after this
break uh gabe sanchez is going to join
us and we're going to do bonehead of the
week soon at this rachel thanks for
joining us we appreciate having you
every single time
see you next time thank you very much
rachel we'll talk to you soon
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking